dress that arrow I believe cool all
right I will save that for when we get
okay from one to all panelists hi so I
see Matthew here I'm Matthew ok wait
tomorrow he'll introduce everyone and
get us all started from Joshua to all
panelists can you hear me geez I don't
know I think we only hear the people who
are actually in the in the discussion so
anyway you hear me Matthew oh here we
got my lady one here okay Chris man my
lady one Matthew okay well Marco show up
in a minute here where is everyone
located Chris where you located I am
right across the border for you actually
I'm in Wisconsin
okay well cross the border and towards
the middle of the continent oh yeah
okay and Matthew where you located I'm
in Ohio USA
okay Ohio and and my lady one where are
you located
can you hear me maybe not okay anyway
over to you mark okay
hi everybody welcome to another
installment of our link gathering I hope
everybody is keeping well under the
circumstances yeah I think we all look
forward to these get-togethers and I
think we're very interested to hear more
from our panelists this week and and see
how you guys use link and just discussed
although those good things about
language learning maybe we can start by
having our guests introduce yourselves
and and then after that I think what
we'd like to do is have you maybe spend
you know a five minutes or so there's
actually I think a fourth panelist well
try and find but yeah
we get we have we're trying to keep this
to an hour so if you can go you know I
don't know five to eight minutes and
then we have a few minutes for questions
leaves us a little bit of time at the
end hopefully to deal with any questions
from from our audience so with that I
don't know Steve if you have anything
you want to add to that you seem to have
muted yours yeah there we go
it's just a Quan I see his name but I
don't see him yet and also my lady wanna
it didn't response I'm wondering if he
can hear us
my anyone yeah I hear you yes okay all
right so where are you located
I'm locating Sweden Oh in Sweden yeah
and Gothenburg Sweden yes you can start
by introducing yourself then okay okay
my name is Michael and I'll be using a
mean Q for about two month but before
then I've been using a lot of different
kind of application specifically a very
much based see how do you call it space
repetition systems but it doesn't really
work out for me and I'll be using a lot
of these so link U is very interesting
because it's a different kind of
approach compared with the other
athletes out there really and I'm trying
to learn polish at the moment and I have
to say that my polish is better now
after two months of use then I want to
say any name but other very big
companies to be using space repetition
systems because it's a very different
kind of learning a fundamental learning
methods I must say well great that's
great to hear maybe why don't you just
step why don't you just go right into
your maybe presentation or talking or
showing us how you use link and then
we'll move on and sort it to the next
person I think that's probably the best
way to go
okay okay and when I come to the way I
use a link is it's just going through
content a lot of content because it's
very big different from from actually
forcing yourself of
things like from from a list of words or
a lots of fresh carbs so I'm doing is
I'm just going through content I'm not
really forcing myself of learning
anything I'm more like trying to
understand the content and I got me
through content by content by content
through all the beginning material of
the beginning material and automatically
naturally I start learning about words
that that coming up not once but but
naturally in a couple of different texts
different contents and in that way it is
much easier to learn so that's one doing
is going through a lots of content
I rarely I know that the repetition has
its value but I rarely do a lot of
repetition I just go for from one
content to next content to next content
yeah every time I use one content I make
sure that I understand that content at
the moment and then I move on I don't go
back to the same content again I just
move on to next content next content so
that is best based one doing and this
gives amazing results actually yeah I
mean I have to say that's I mean that's
how I use link I might almost never do
any review I just move on from one
content that into the next and all of a
sudden you realize that you you know the
word the other words that you're seeing
I know that word now I didn't must not
have known it before but I know it now
and I move it to known and I just keep
going in you may start slowly but over
time you just I know most of the words
on the page just happens without doing
any dedicated review dedicated SRS flash
carting whatever you want to call it so
I'm glad to hear you find the same yeah
I have the same experience when it comes
to lean Q and that is the only learning
learning method I've seen that work this
way
so that's interesting is this like a its
new way to go yeah it's very interesting
it is but one thing that I know as well
that I think was very important to begin
is that when I when I
looking at the content this since I'm is
the language I'm trying to learn now
it's a pretty new language to me I found
out that it's so important for me to
read the text in the same time as I'm
listening because that is the this will
give me most effect when it comes to to
learn languages instead of just
listening and trying to force myself to
understand what they are saying
specifically new content and
specifically if you not need
specifically if you quite new to that
kind of language I noticed that by
reading in the same time as listening it
gives you you know like maybe triple at
peak efficiency okay we just listening
because in the beginning you you just
hear noise you cannot understand what
the same but if you read it and then you
listen and then next time you read it
again and listening in the same time I
mean in the end you were here directly
what they're saying but you know exactly
how it looks like you can actually see
the word itself but if you just
listening it would take a lot of time
before you actually start here the the
specific words now are difficult to to
to learn by just listening you see that
is my experience I definitely not what
I'm studying Swedish Swedish I can't
remember which that our beginner courses
on link and I can remember reading along
and it's like wow he said that many
times
my lady one I didn't get your name when
you introduce yourself and Michael
Michael okay thank you yeah yeah I know
that definitely is some powerful at the
beginning especially is that ability to
listen and read along and and then over
time you just as once you've done that
as you say you can you can then just
listen after a while and you know what
they're saying yeah yeah I think one of
the biggest mistake is like to try
learn the text like in other areas like
I have to know this text automatically
without I not only what the text is
about I have to know the text completely
I have to understand every word and and
how this word is bent
exactly I mean if you're going with that
kind of approach I mean you don't you
don't come forward with content if you
trying to you know like your nail every
content that you read it's almost
impossible you become just too much but
if you only have one goal and that will
be like just understand the text both by
reading and then maybe listening and
reading in the same time that's the way
to go I believe yeah I know that's one
of Steve's big big points and you may
want to expand on it but so many people
just think they I have to learn this a
hundred percent before I move on and
you're not gonna remember it a hundred
percent and you need to move on it maybe
Stevie you want to expand oh no I just
think sometimes I think I once did have
a sort of declaration of rights of
language learners language learner has
the right to not understand
misunderstand obviously make mistakes
it's my language I'm reacting with it I
move on when I understand forty percent
simply because I'm bored so the brain
likes repetition but the light the brain
likes new things so I gone to the next
and the next and the next which is easy
to do in the mini-stories area because
there's a lot of repetition and every
one of those the other thing I was gonna
say is you know listening strategy
reading strategy obviously at the
beginning you can't understand what
you're listening to so you definitely I
find I want to listen and read at least
once to get some sense of what's being
said and look upwards but then because
the listening is so easy to do
independently of reading like I don't
want to spend my day in front of my iPad
or computer so inevitably I do a lot of
listening away from the computer the
same parts that I don't understand and
then I go back and read it again so I
think there's a mixture of reading and
listening at the same time listening on
its own and sometimes reading on its own
it's powerful because when you're
listening and reading you're not putting
the same effort into reading as when you
are just reading and I find that
particularly the case with Arabic and
where I have to force myself to try and
read those letters and if I'm hearing it
at the same time it's a bit of a crutch
like a training wheel so I think we can
experiment with all kinds of different
listening and reading strategies but I
don't again I can come back later when I
hear everyone else's point of view on
this all right okay so anything else you
wanted to add Michael no that's pretty
much it what about the process of
learning in some way that you know like
you you getting the right start that is
there is so important in in every
learning methods I think but
specifically in this one and I think
it's very important that they're not
getting stuck in in material too long
it's like you just get bored and then is
there very hard progress because
learning so it's so specific in a
comprehensive material it's not going to
work really I think it's really really
important to just move on move on move
on I think it natural yeah for sure and
we appreciate the nice to hear you but
had these revelations that we we are
strong believers in so yeah thanks very
much for for sharing what you do and
yeah good good good luck in your ongoing
all right yeah thanks a lot much it's ok
smell nice to be able to speak about it
Thanks maybe Chris you can go next maybe
I tell us who you are and and sure sure
so my name is Chris I've been using Lync
for about eight or nine months now I'm
primarily using it to study Arabic but
also picked up French about a month and
a half two months ago just as kind of a
hobby language I came into link learning
Arabic as kind of a low intermediate
already I went to school for
international politics and relations and
my focus was on the Middle East and
North Africa
so naturally I learned Arabic I did a
study abroad in Jordan and everything so
I had a bit of experience with the
language already but to be honest my
time in Arabic classes in school was
kind of miserable for many of the
reasons that I think a lot of people
have issues with in classes in school in
general you know the focus on grammar
instruction testing which I don't like
at all
not enough peer reading and listening
and it just kind of drove me away from
the language a little while so I took
about nine months off until I graduated
that what bat slipped right away and as
soon as I discovered link I was hooked
because once I started reading the news
from BBC Arabic al Jazeera etcetera just
over and over and over again every day I
was picking up so much speed so quickly
and I went I still got started with link
at about three thousand word count
Arabic pretty quickly from the stuff I
already do but right now I'm sitting
almost 13,000 and I never could have
imagined myself learning this language
that quickly much more enjoyable than
previous methods my foot hop
modern Standard Arabic for those who
don't know that word has skyrocketed
dramatically especially in the reading
Department although I certainly could do
more listening and then I've been
focusing mostly on Levantine Arabic as
well which has been nice importing my
material from other sources into length
to help facilitate that I do use some of
the resources on there for Levantine
that are already unlinked but what I
found is that it's a little easier for
me to find material outside of it and it
imported in to just make it easier for
me to read on the website so basically I
learned the same way that Mike I believe
was your name said had many other pieces
of link described it's lots of reading
over and over left listening I barely
ever do the SRS review I looked at my
total number of review terms for Arabic
and I think it's sitting around like
24,000 there's no way I'm going to
review all those so I'm gonna stick with
reading and that's fine with me and
that's that's the thing I really love
about
is how easy it makes reading I love to
read just in English my parents poked
fun of me sometimes for when I was in
school as a kid I would read underneath
my desk instead of paying attention to
life chemistry and I like I like being
able to read in any language so I want
to read pretty much anything I have in
Arabic the only issue I found with that
with Lync is that I noticed that you can
import ebooks in other languages a lot
I've seen a lot of you books in French
and Spanish I didn't notice that you
can't really do that with Arabic because
there seems to be an issue with Arabic
on Kindle desktop and some other desktop
apps because you need desktop to import
into links so I have to do all of my
reading through Kindle on my phone which
gets the job done but it's not nearly as
fun as you think I'm linked but despite
that reading Harry Potter in Arabic has
been a blast
although slow and painful
so yeah it's lots of listening lots of
reading trying to import lessons that I
get from my I talkie tooter into links
like I studied them later
put it on my phone and read everything
and listen to everything when I have the
chance and I try to listen to the radio
a little bit in addition to that and
interestingly I wasn't expecting this
all the reading that I'm doing in the
news and from the france24
podcasts that have been shared a link
which was it from you see if I don't
recall those are shared by you I don't
necessarily need to hear all of the
things I'm reading because obviously
there's no professional audio for every
news article but what I find is that
even just lots and lots of reading helps
me hear BBC Arabic better and that's
been really cool which is nice because
BBC Arabic is really hard still add the
more progress I can make without the
better because I love BBC and NPR and
radios like that so overall it's been a
really great experience
I had three years roughly of just
miserable Arabic classes I think a big
part of that was one to focus on the
skill based learning and the really bad
textbook said nobody likes even the
teachers and this has been a joy to
learn Arabic and a little bit of French
I'm like so thank you to the link team
and everybody puts out content because I
don't know what would have happened with
my Arabic without discovering like
honestly I probably would have tried
something else so yeah that's kind of
the gist of it really oh great great to
hear glad you're enjoying it one comment
about the EE books and I found the same
in Japanese it's it's it's the importing
of e-books from Kindle and it's
difficult for some languages I guess I
had no problem in Italian and I wasn't
using Amazon books which are a little
trickier to deal with but Japanese I'm
having trouble with the ebooks I'm you
know over time we hope we can maybe
start to figure out better ways of
getting books into instantly because I
personally I love being able to read
books on link I've it's just such a
great source of word rich content which
I'm kind of missing in Japanese which I
had in Italian anyway that was one
observation but yes I comment a bit on
the Arabic first of all I'm struggling
with my Arabic - I cart used the many
stories a lot because I was starting
from zero and the first obstacle was to
get used to the writing system which
even when you understand basically what
the letters are supposed to represent
and it's not that consistent but just to
get used to reading it just takes so
much so much reading and then yeah I'm
responsible for importing that stuff
from phosphide cut hope they don't come
after us cuz I did you sent them emails
asking and they never responded so okay
we're gonna use it if they tell us that
take it down we'll take our take it down
and then I've been using the Levantine
Arabic many stories just to get a flavor
of Levantine Arabic
it's surprisingly recognizable like you
get the feeling that it's all part of
one big system it's not I thought that
it was very very different and when I
started in the Arabic if you read the
books that they used to teach Arabic and
seven different types of verbs and all
kinds of junk like that it you know it
would just say okay I'm not gonna learn
this language like it's just so
complicated
when you actually get into it and
experience those things in fact it's not
so complicated in other words the effort
to explain something that you can
actually naturally get used to it just
makes it more complicated and right
before it doesn't help so and I'm
definitely lots of listening and reading
with my Arabic and I'm gonna try out the
BBC and I'm doing Persian at the same
time so that kind of right I imagine
that thinks in particular but it gets
you more practice 3 exactly that's why I
dropped the Turkish to me I want to get
better at reading that's so important
yeah oh and I wanted to say with regard
to Polish I found great polish ebooks
for which there were audio books from it
was Publio krupka pale and so there and
and in those days there were no
restrictions so I haven't been to polish
in the last couple of years but you can
you know there was none of this whatever
it's called lock down on them DMD or
whatever it's called Karim yeah so I
don't know what the situation is now but
for Polish there's lots of ebooks audio
TECA has ebooks ebooks with
corresponding audio books which is a
delight if you're learning a language
anyway I just thought I'd throw that in
there yeah yeah thanks okay well great
again thanks thanks Chris for sharing
good luck with the with the Arabic and
the French now and see you around our
community in the future and and everyone
can feel free to comment it's it's it is
a panel here so we'll continue along
Matthew maybe you can you can introduce
yourself and go next and go from there
thank you everyone it's honor to be here
it's great to meet everyone and on the
zoom call and I have I have been using
link III I'm distinguished my experience
with link in two distinct phases the
first phase last lasted just over 30
days and
the current phase that I'm on has I'm
I'm about a year and a half in I am on
I'm learning Spanish I was I had no
formal education at Spanish in school
but I have a number of spanish-speaking
colleagues and a number of international
multilingual colleagues so I've always
had a passion for languages I just don't
believe I've ever really had an
effective method until now used several
well-known programs but nothing would be
type of success that I have found with
link the first phase that I use linked
with I was I was not maximizing the full
effectiveness of the program I was
basically reading and linking only not
taking advantage of the listening
component and then once I realized that
I was missing that I utilized both
reading and listening and my personal
strategy is when I find it when I get to
a new lesson
I eat regardless of what the percentage
is of mine own words I will listen to
the to the lesson this is my this is my
way it may seem tedious to some but I
listen to it at half speed and then and
then that's if I had to look up every
single word that's what I do that's when
I highlight the phrases that I need to
to to to link and then that's when I go
through and link the the new words and
then I will listen to the same lesson
again at at point six six speed then at
point seven five speed and then at point
nine speed and what I do there when I
want to get to the point nine speed is
is I will go phrase by phrase and then I
will stop it and then repeat it and say
it out loud and I do it until I get it
perfect at least - Maya - Maya
satisfactory accent pronunciation rhythm
tone everything and then because one of
my biggest difficulties with Spanish is
the the speed of the spoken form of the
language I will then go to double speed
and then go to one and a half speed and
then finally I go to normal speed and
then by the time I've gone from double
speeds normal speed that seems pretty
pretty slow
and so consequently especially with the
phase of when I when I wasn't realizing
that I need to be listening as well my
statistics are sort of lagging
behind my own word count in Spanish
right now is around 10,500 a little bit
higher and then but I so but I consider
myself as far as the link from brackets
I would be considered to be one but I
consider myself either very close to be
two if not be two in actuality I've
actually if this was totally unprepared
and unplanned but I actually translated
a conversation for two of my monolingual
colleagues and I know I butchered it I
know I made mistakes but the English
colleague was happy and the
spanish-speaking colleague was happy and
so it was quite an experience for me but
but that that's my current strategy and
then when I when I listened to it
finally on for the seventh time on the
on the full speed that's when I go
through and I'm and I take words that I
feel comfortable with too and move them
to known and and I did dabble with
German last fall stuck with it for sixty
days and then and then drop did I do
plan and go back going back to it but
when we get the QA phase I do have a a
burning question for it for mr. Kaufman
for for for my my personal next steps
but that's that's that's how I currently
use link it trying to incorrect I'm with
everyone else I I have used this the
spaced repetition system some but not
anymore I just basically just turned
through new content and try to listen as
much as I can yeah great it's very
interesting to hear that of your
approach there in the listening and I'm
sure that's effective
yeah it's especially you know early on
in the language where you're having
trouble distinguishing one words from
word from the next you know it right and
I'll also add the majority of my current
colleagues who are who are Spanish
speaking are from the Caribbean and if
anyone is familiar with Spanish they
know the Caribbean Spanish is it's it's
next level fast and and so that has been
a challenge just in that accident this
is the this is my personal feeling so
far the easiest accents for me to
comprehend
on on the fly are either the accents
from Mexico or from Spain themselves
I've had difficulty with some of the
argentine and uruguayan accidents but
but you know with enough practice i can
i can comprehend it and then then my
friends live from the caribbean they
just it's so fast so that's I understand
it well other than just the speed of it
hmm I just might make a couple of
comments here too I agree with you by
the way that Mexican Mexican to me is
the easiest to understand Spanish is a
little bit machine gun but the Caribbean
and the Chilean Spanish where they don't
pronounce their asses those are the most
difficult to understand all sorry it was
interesting to hear you describe your
strategy I think and I've said this
before like language learning is a
personal journey we do it for ourselves
we do it in the way that we find the
most effective and the most enjoyable so
we're gonna have some differences in
approach I think is very important to
believe in whatever strategy you're
using I think that's more important than
trying to evaluate whether my strategy
is better than somebody else's strategy
the the idea is you got to find a
strategy that works for you and believe
in it you think it's worthwhile
worthwhile putting the time in and
you're gonna succeed so you know you
have an approach to listening that it's
different from mine but it works for you
you believe in it therefore you're gonna
succeed in it how would you mind if I
comment on that real quick yeah that was
my personal experience with Arabic as I
said before the we had the same routine
way of approaching Arabic in school and
with lots of standardized testing and
grammar and I specifically remember
telling one of my teachers that I wasn't
really learning and engaged because it
just wasn't any fun for me just give me
something to read and I'll learn and I
actually remember being scoffs deaf I
asked a certain teacher for that
comments and I think that's kind of an
ingrained educational thing that I wish
more people would more teachers
specifically gain more open mind on that
sort of thing branching out different
ways of teaching because not all of us
want to have a standardized tests
grammar based approach
be nice if we had more variety there I
don't know many I don't think many want
to have grammar tests I could be wrong
there are some we get comments on link
how come there's not more of that but
not much I mean I think stephen krashen
commented that those people are the ones
that become language teachers so yeah
great
well yeah Matthew super interesting very
much appreciate you sharing your story
and glad to hear you're obviously making
progress and and interacting with your
your spanish-speaking colleagues that's
great great to hear and so now you wanna
how about you maybe I introduce yourself
and tell us your story okay so you can
hear me clearly I guess yeah I had some
technical issues that's why no I made my
entrance so basically I'm from Greece
[Music]
I'm located right now in in Germany in
Auckland and I'm working as a software
engineer I've been using Lync since like
I think it's with some some intervals
some time intervals like some months on
and off about four years I think I've
used I've used it like extensively for
probably a bunch of languages mostly
your European languages like that's
that's the case for me I haven't used it
yet for Chinese or for Japanese like I
haven't learned yet it's kind of like
more exotic languages if you were to put
it this way and yeah what basically how
am I using it I I don't I do not like
Lisa I do not listen to much like a link
I don't know why but I had since like I
started with French and Spanish
I was doing mostly reading and speed
reading in in my first steps in a
language let's say if I start now like
language that is similar to the language
that I already know I'll start with
probably like an A to B one kind of
level like articles or blogs or whatever
I can import stuff things that my car
that interest me and yeah like I do I do
really enjoy like creating links and you
know reading extensively sometimes yeah
you you get the gist that that you're
not like really paying attention to the
to the text and it's it's like blurring
like like it learn those ways like you
just read it and it's like what did I
just read yeah it's it's true but you
know the more you read the thing and the
more you you listen like I usually
listen to maybe some you know YouTube
videos like to watch youtubers who are
native speakers who also talk like the
the everyday language which is sometimes
like for being in my case in German
language the the everyday language has
some nuances that you can find them
probably like in the articles or books
or whatever so yeah a lot of lots lots
of reading I really know note some key
words maybe that I do I do think that
they're relevant they are a higher
relevancy like like Lou Calipari yellow
you should say like go for high Latrell
at the relevancy high relevance sorry
and yeah and then maybe I'll review them
but but I'll try to like I set a goal
every day let's say in German now I want
you to increase my word count for 150
words
my work come every day I want to no
matter how many links I create I have to
increase my my number of worth like 150
per day and I try to do that
consistently and I did that like with
all of the languages that I tried to
learn and I think that that gives me
like the result it's not about because
I've tried to go and like for hire but
you can really spin be motivated if you
like go sometimes like really high and
like you're right off just that's too
much okay you're probably going to give
up so like I find that a hundred or 150
words per day it's quite you know a
sweet spot maybe I don't know whatever
about you guys like how what's like
maybe your goals like but that's how I
you know I how I use it at least and
yeah pretty much that [ __ ]
there's no I think magic trick now
everybody will agree on that like keep
on doing that and it will eventually
like it will eventually work but I I did
I did learn quite a lot of chairmen like
in the past let's say five months
because I already had some ground-based
knowledge because I did I have like a d1
certificate from an age ago so yeah I
did have some like knowledge but link
really helped me to step up like in the
more advanced stages I believe now I'm
like I'm going I'm going through the
intermediate barrier right now so
interesting did when you said when you
said a hundred and fifty words at a year
you your goal is to increase your known
words by 150 yeah yeah so that means
like either like going from yellow to
white yeah just like good from from blue
to white mm-hmm and like the more you
read the more you you encounter some
words you will eventually know them yeah
yeah well that's interesting that
approach I've never really thought of
using a no more
or daily no more sorry I mean I guess we
have those targets on the site but I
don't tend to focus on that but it's
maybe an interesting thing to do
although I find in Japanese right now
I'm having a harder time growing mine
own words then I did you do when you do
a language like in Italian where there's
so much common vocabulary with English
it's more easier to grow your didn't
know especially early in Japanese where
you don't know a word until you've seen
it and looked it up and then seen it
many more times it's a slower progress
but probably I mean if you do enough
reading and listening you'll eventually
start to see those words enough that you
start to know them it's no different it
just it's more difficult to grow your
vocabulary and I think one last thing
I'm sorry so I see a bit like of just
like let's say two small conversations
per per week like I have a language
tandem in Serbian right now and she's a
girl who's living in Greece and she
learns Greek and I learned Serbian so we
do like little tandem exchange one or
two times a week that really like helps
to you know build up more confidence and
more like connect with the language and
it's somebody who's like a native
speaker so it's like you're winning like
both both both sides winning thanks for
having me no I I was just gonna comment
and then we can maybe open it for
questions that one of the things I find
is that what motivates me can vary from
you know at different times so for
example when I started on going after
three languages Turkish Arabic and
Persian I set the goal of creating a
hundred links a day in each language
which was ridiculous I'd be there at
10:30 at night I haven't done my Turkish
links don't find something and just
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding create a
hundred links you know so you can be
motivated by moving from blue to yellow
sometimes I'm motivated by wanting to
move from yellow to white and so then I
go back into lessons that I've already
studied and
and see if I don't know the words I'll
sometimes cheat and go to the vocab page
and of course the vocab page lines up
alphabetically or I set it to line up
alphabetically so I'm going to see and
even in Arabic I'm going to see four or
five words that are part of the same
word you know you'll find that you saved
these words you saved three or four or
five different forms of the same word
but that also helps you to see them and
then I kind of say well maybe I know
this one
so I'll move them over to white but I'm
never afraid to move it to white because
if I find that I don't know the word I
moved back to yellow so there's never a
danger there are people are so uptight
you know I don't want to say I know this
word because what if I don't know it
okay you know it in this context you may
forget it next week anyway it doesn't
matter say you know it and if you don't
know it you can move it back to yellow
so but I think there is some benefit in
having these somewhat artificial goals
because you're most the time are
motivated by content maybe or like
listening to me is the easiest thing to
do so I always use you know listen to
the course audio I open a course I go
listen to the course audio I've got that
with me for the day I'm listening a
whole bunch of things that I don't
understand
then I'm motivated to go back and then
read it so that the listening is easy to
do so that's a motivation it's easy and
then you listen you don't understand so
there's motivation then to read so you
can be motivated you know in different
ways at different times but sometimes
just a simple thing like it's as if
someone said and here's a pile of a
hundred stones I want you to take each
little stone and move it over there and
create another pile there's some sense
of satisfaction of actually having done
something completely stupidly mechanical
so if you say I need to create whatever
15 links or move X number of words or
create a hundred no new non words you
have sort of like a mechanical so it
forces you to do it when some of the
other sort of intrinsic motivations are
kind of flagging a bit so I think
variety is is so key and all of our
learning activities so that when we're
motivated in a certain way we run with
that motivation when we don't have that
motivation we run with some other kind
of motivation and when we aren't
particularly
motivate and we give ourselves some
artificial you know tasks to do just to
stay the course anyway that was just my
and I should say I loved learning Greek
and then my wife I went to Crete and I
was able to use it but don't speak to me
in Greek right now I might have to later
yeah
but yeah okay that's what adds it great
well that concludes the presentation
segment
I very much appreciate all of you
sharing your stories a very interesting
for me and no doubt for for the rest of
our audience today
now we have lots of time for questions
which is great and I see we have lots of
questions building up including someone
who wants to speak Persian with Steve we
may I don't know if we'll have time for
that but someone's asking certain a
language in order to be consistent on
your learning journey Steve maybe well
you know 30 minutes like I would say
that without even trying I'll get in 45
minutes to an hour of listening every
day that's not difficult
I get up I make breakfast there's 20
minutes I cleared the dishes after
breakfast there's another 20 minutes 15
minutes or so if I get in the car if I
go for a walk if I work out there's all
there's an hour so now you've got an
hour free so then the question to me is
how much additional time you're gonna
spend how much time am I gonna spend on
the iPad to try to understand what I
listen to and I think you should spend
at least 30 minutes reading or doing
something other than that free listening
time so it comes to an hour and a half
to two hours and if you do that you know
how quickly can I learn like that's
always the question I have no answer for
that question but you will achieve a
noticeable breakthrough if you do that
every day like the free time for
listening plus another 30 40 minutes
spent reading that would be my answer no
promises though
anyone else who wants to chime in feel
free and and I think too if someone ever
I think was Matthew had some questions
that he wanted to ask or we can also
have some questions amongst ourselves as
well as responding to the questions we
get from the people watching for sure
yes sir is now a good time I don't want
to interrupt anyone else yeah go for it
and one thing that I didn't mention as
well and this goes in to what Steve just
mentioned after I go through that be
routine of leap reading and listening
that for each lesson that I mentioned
earlier
I will then during free time you know
chores around the house driving on the
road then I will go back to my playlist
and then and for me I've seen that it's
easier for me to comprehend if I do it
after I've gone through that process of
reading so I did so it's it's sort of a
converse and but the same strategy I
would I would say my question was and
again I like I mentioned I had no formal
training in in Spanish whatsoever I did
have three years of formal training in
French and like most people could
probably say I don't speak French three
years of formal education in Latin which
has produced many dividends as far as
word constructors and roots and things
like that as far as as far as Spanish
and French are concerned I've read
different schools of thought on this but
I'm itching and burning to go on to to
to basically conquer that unconquered so
from my years of school and go on into
French but I don't want to being from
the same language family there are some
who say you shouldn't do that until you
have a solid base my question is would
anyone here recommend with my basically
B to stand and then the foundation that
I had in French and Latin would I be
running into a risk at doing that now or
should I go further into Spanish first I
want to maintain my Spanish while I do
French I just wanted to get anyone's
take on that can I add something here
yes sure okay yeah I was like in the
similar
creation with you when I was I was I was
I started learning Italian because I
wanted to go to Erasmus in Italy and
yeah at the same time I was like I was
eating yeah I had like the same thing
with you and I wanted to learn French
and Spanish so yeah I started French
about when I was let's say three four
months in with Italian so I was pretty
much a beginner in Italian and like yeah
I did like normal things some words did
like mixed up yeah that's like quite
normal but but now like most of the
times when I when I when I speak in the
language yeah I do remember like the
equivalent of Italian and most of the
times it's quite similar to you know
Spanish or French so you can use that in
your own advantage now that you're like
progressing in Spanish that you like you
have a really good solid base you can
like really go on and then tackle
already like a to be one material right
away so that's what I will do I would I
would do like if I were you that's my
point
thank you a go ahead Steve I'm you know
I was gonna say my response you're
having for the longest time said that
you should only study one language at
one time and that came from my
experience with Chinese where I went at
it like just like a lunatic like I just
totally focused on Chinese some extent
you know the more you concentrate the
more you focus the more intense you know
the in a way the faster you're gonna
learn but I've changed my position right
now and what I now feel is that first of
all having read a bit about the brain
likes novelty so you go into French
you're gonna find that exciting because
you know the first three four months in
a language are in a way it's called the
honeymoon period we go from zero okay it
won't be zero for you because you had it
in school but but you'll get that
excitement of rediscovering and in fact
doing French on link you'll move much
more quickly than you ever did in your
classroom so the whole thing will be fun
and so but will your Spanish suffer I
don't think so
in fact my experience is that your
Spanish will improve the only downside
is that of course you're spending less
time on Spanish so to that extent you're
not adding new words as quickly however
going back and forth from French to
Spanish yeah I believe it's good for the
brain it's good for the flexibility it
keeps the brain motivated you know again
I've this for example professor Robert
Bjork at UCLA who talks about the fact
that if we try to stay with learning one
thing we're getting less and less
effective all the time but to some
extent this interleaving of varying
things actually helps the brain to learn
so I would definitely is particularly
and the fact that they're related
languages it's not a big deal you will
put you know get some Spanish in your
french and vice versa so what and then
if you as you continue in the one or the
other you'll do that less often so there
might be some initial interference but
but I think all of us as language
learners have to accept that we're gonna
make mistakes there's gonna be
interference from other languages I love
it for example Swedes I always love it
when they speak English speaking is so
well but there's one thing that they
cannot get away from they always say it
is when it should be there are so it is
many problems in language learning is
the Swedes will say that no matter how
well I speak English is always it is so
instead of there are so there are always
going to be these interferences one way
or the other but I think that you'll
find that your Spanish will improve
you'll find it more interesting and
you'll have to decide and it might very
weak the weak how much time you put into
French how much time you put into
Spanish your Spanish will improve your
ability to comprehend things will
improve your language learning fitness
will improve the only thing is you won't
be growing your vocabulary in Spanish as
quickly as you are now thank you thank
you so much in my thinking was with my
three years in French and three years in
Latin but I'm it once I dive into French
I might just whereas with Spanish I
started at the basic I mean a one new
beginner content but with French I'm
thinking that I may just dive headfirst
into the many stories and just try to
plow through and see how quickly I can
go I start every landing
now with the mini stories it started
with me I went from zero and Greek
couldn't read Greek couldn't understand
just noise many stories Arabic Persian
every lamb Turkish the many stories but
I listen to them a lot like I go lesson
one two three four five back to one
I got it on listen to course audio so I
end up listening to these things twenty
thirty times because your challenge in
French is not going to be reading it the
reading part you'll get fairly quickly
the challenge is going to be hearing it
with a liaison work where one you know
the last syllable flows into the next
syllable it's a different experience
from Spanish but yeah absolutely you can
start with the many stories and in fact
you can be doing many stories and
bringing in news articles from
newspapers and you'll be able to
understand those but you still need the
many stories in order to get the brain
used to the sounds and the structures
that whole French experience even though
you'll be able to access fairly advanced
reading material fairly early thank you
very much that helps a lot thank you
ball great a question here how often do
you review links if at all and do you
move on to new content instead and try
to encounter the unknown words again I
mean I think we have probably have
covered that already in this talk so
maybe we won't answer that again but
fundamentally most of us here don't do
the review much if at all and and move
on relatively quickly without having to
understand the whole thing one comment
when I begin in the language is the time
when I do most of the review and I do
the review as I turn the page and
typically even at the very beginning I'm
in sentence view because it's like
Arabic like I know nothing and then I'll
review as I turn the page and then if
I'm in page view in Arabic I'll also
review as I turn the page at the
beginning but I don't do that anymore
even in Arabic so that's only they get a
toehold at the beginning and then I do
but that's individual everyone has a
different approach if I might ask one
thing as well um when I'm the beginner
did the same thing as Steve if I do a
little bit of review I might do that in
French what I found though is that if
you do a lot of reading especially if
you go on multiple articles
four books on similar subjects all these
words are gonna show up again and again
again that's how I learned how to read
the news in Arabic is if there are
important things going on in the world
you're gonna keep seeing the vocabulary
from those things you're gonna just pick
them up I never do
SRS review for media Arabic because I
don't need to because the same things
keep popping up again again again so
don't feel too nervous about that if
something is important or you're
interested in it you're gonna see it
over and over again as I say a Steve has
said many times is it's like the
snowball gathering be going down the
hill gathering mass going down the hill
it starts slowly because until you've
seen words however many times it takes
you still don't know them and then all
of a sudden you realize it I know all of
these words or more and more and more of
these words and my page is getting less
and less yellow over time there's less
and less highlighting it just happens
you just kind of have to believe in the
process I think I'm sorry I I do I'm
sorry mark I do the exact opposite of
Steve I try to you know SRS words now
that I'm like more advanced and have
like almost I think I have fifty fifty
thousand words on German right now link
no words so I try now to read you some
words rather than like in the very
beginning where I try to you know listen
and read this message I came because I
think like deliberate study really know
fills up the gaps that you have like
after point maybe so I just like to put
it out there probably yeah that's good
but I do agree with Steve like what he
said yeah well I mean yeah as we've said
there's the you find what works for you
and and that's your one thing I think we
all agree on is to get the volume of
words that you need you actually can't
get it from SRS review because it takes
much time to get the volume of words
that you need you just get by exposure
because it's the most efficient way I
the review can help it
to get to the toehold one as you're
pointing out it later on you're trying
to fill in gaps definitely you can focus
on specific areas and do review because
it it reinforces but one thing that we
stress at link is that you know you you
need I don't know in what every language
is different but 30,000 40,000 50,000
words you can't learn that many words
using SRS it's it's it's just not it's
just not possible it's also matter if I
could just interject it's also a matter
of what motivates you if you are
motivated to try and knock off these
words and hawin probably is going after
quite low frequency words that don't
show up very often and he's trying to
work through his flashcards or whatever
system he uses to do that and if that's
what motivates you that's fine if if I
look at what I'm now doing in Persian
where I have there's a lady in Iran who
has created this history of Iran and
she's put in ten lessons so far my only
motivation is to learn about the history
of Iran I'm not I don't care how many
words I'm learning how many links have
created none of that motivates me she
sends a new one every three four days
and you know we've now entered the
Islamic period in Iran and I'm it's just
fascinating so the motivation is to
learn about the history of Iran I'm not
conscious of trying to deliberately
increase so it depends on what your
motivation is I think when we get more
advanced in the language
if we find motivating content the
motivations that takes over is the
interest in the subject matter and then
everything else kind of falls into place
why do you in once case where he's
actually in Germany you're probably
noticing gaps and you need your language
needs to be better a year you're a
Persian doesn't need to be you're not
learning Iran that's a very good point
very good point living he I wanna keeps
on seeing words that he needs to know
and doesn't know and he's gonna go in
there and nail them I understand that
entirely um what is the recommended pace
for graduating from level to level b1 to
b2 to c1 and so forth
well you know my view on this is that
recognize that those levels a 1 a 2
etcetera are extremely arbitrary now
they can have tests for them but you
know B 1 in what reading and listening
and speaking I mean they're completely
arbitrary the biggest distance in my
mind is from b1 to b2 in other words
where you've kind of passed the beginner
stage and you aren't yet fluent that
takes a long time and I'm talking six
months nine months longer depending on
the language and that's the period where
you're consuming lots of content there's
still lots of words you don't know
because the word frequency declines so
quickly that new words show up less and
less often so I think it's I don't think
we should be looking at how much time I
think we should be motivated to stay
with the process stay with the task and
you will see results a somewhat related
question how many know one word should I
expect to be mildly comfortable with the
language given that I came to the
language with some background knowledge
of it and I anyway go ahead Steve well I
mean the first question is which
language obviously you know if it's a
language if it's a Romance language and
you're an English speaker then you've
got a lot of automatic vocabulary but I
found when the way we count words at
link if I look at my experience with
Czech and polish and Greek and Romanian
and Korean its way up there it's like
40,000 words it's not 15,000 words yeah
yeah I mean I think that's something
that a lot of users don't really grasp
this is actually you need to get through
a lot of content you need to generate a
lot of make a lot of links see a lot of
words your known words total needs to be
significant and that's why so many of
these other approaches are just not
effective because you learn so little
that even if you learn it you're nowhere
and and and to get somewhere you need
yeah whatever you said forty thousand
words thirty thousand words like you
want to be able to understand ones
peoples
you you want to be able to read the news
you want to be able to listen to the
podcasts and radio and so on yeah that's
that's the vocabulary and the thing
about the known words totally is so
people challenge it well you see you
know sixty thousand words and this and I
do you don't really and stuff it doesn't
matter what what they what it actually
means in any objective sense what it
means though is that you have put in a
lot of time with the language so you
have done a lot of reading and probably
of listening to that same material and
for your brain to get used to the
language to where it's comfortable with
the language requires a lot of input so
the known words total is along with
links created it's just an indication of
how much you have been involved with the
language and if you only have ten
thousand words I you may come with
thirty thousand words from a previous
experience or you grew up with the
language fine but if you're doing it on
link and you have forty thousand words
you have engaged with the language a lot
and that's so that's kind of it's a bit
of a milestone indicator and when you go
from 40 to 50 that means that you have
spent that much more time with the
language so it's not something you can
go brag to people I know fifty thousand
words it's not what it means is I have
spent a lot of time with the language
and if I might add one thing I wouldn't
I caution people to not get too caught
up in setting like pace goals or workout
goals what I found is that especially in
my case that can add extra pressure
which takes away from your enjoyment of
the language I don't have that in French
because printer is a hobby language but
Arabic is pretty important for my
professional interests but if you don't
have that sort of thing hanging over you
like I imagine salon does living in
Germany and having to use German all the
time relax enjoy the process spend some
time with it every day and you're gonna
get there the most important thing is
just do what you enjoy and don't get
stressed out about it because you're
gonna learn a lot faster if you're
having fun and you're not stressed out
and that's why I like link a lot because
it takes a lot of that stress factor out
of
so I make sure people keep that in mind
good good points for sure
someone's asking would it be just as
effective to read a book with a
dictionary and turn the words you don't
know into Anki flashcards ah Steve go
ahead maybe you can well first of all
the dictionary if you're talking about a
dictionary that you leave through I
would say that's one of the biggest time
wasters there is in language learning it
takes quite a while to find that word as
opposed to clicking online if you are
reading online I have never gone to the
trouble of creating lists let alone an
key card so there's another expenditure
of time so I mean there are people who
love doing Anki so for them that might
work but for me part of why we created
link is because I had books here at home
in Spanish and German and the rewards
that I didn't know and every time I'd
read them I'd underline them then I take
my underlying pages and go to the
dictionary and look them up and make a
list and it never amounted to anything I
would forget all of those so link
actually is another approach no Anki no
making lists no looking up in
conventional dictionaries get the
meaning right away and we call it a hint
and the meaning the dictionary meaning
is not something you're gonna remember
because you're gonna forget it but it's
to get you through the text because your
focus is trying to understand the text
but then whatever you've looked up shows
up again and it shows up again and
gradually as Mark said all of a sudden
there's no more yellow on your page or
the I mean even on my Arabic there's a
little bit of blue a little bit of y'all
lots of white I still think I don't
understand the language but my link page
is telling me that I do and so to my
mind that's a better way than looking
things up and making Anki cards and
going through your Anki deck you're not
gonna get the 40,000 known words on that
basis not not in a short time anyways
but whatever people like to do yeah
here's there's a few is there a quick
method of importing Russian text into
link for sure if
you're asking that question I assume you
are not familiar with our browser
extension so you should definitely in
the sidebar and at least in the web
you'll see links to our extensions for
Firefox Safari and Chrome in the mobile
app you can also turn on our sharing
extension in the share menu which you
can activate from you what your your
mobile browser or even Twitter I believe
definitely get yourself familiar with
our browser extension it's just a few
simple settings and then one click
import of news articles YouTube videos
Netflix captions you name it the the
browser extension is definitely the way
to go
what about link for teachers any tips I
assume and we have a teacher interface
there is a banner which appears at some
point that directing teachers to find
that interface you can set up your
classrooms on link and invite students
to your classrooms but I assume you're
asking about using link as a teacher we
don't have sort of specific ways
guidelines about how to use link with
your class one thing I would like to
point out is that in that teacher
interface in addition obviously to
inviting your students you have the
ability to choose material from our
library and add it to a shelf so to
speak in the library so that you can
have a an area in in the library for
your students called you know whatever
marks classroom and in it you can attach
courses from our library so that you can
identify courses that you maybe want
yours to focus on
you've been import materials you may
have materials that your students need
to study you can import that material
and restricted only to your class
members obviously we believe that
students should be free to find content
that they're interested in but
understand that there is often class
material that has to be covered and and
it helps do
who may not be motivated to find their
own content to direct them at courses
certainly the many stories would be one
that comes to mind I don't know Steve if
you have suggestions on how teachers
might use Ostrom I think you know
because we aren't teachers ourselves we
would be very interested to hear from
teachers about how they would use it in
the classroom you know I don't know you
know depends on the age of the students
would they actually go away and listen
and read would you have them read in the
classroom would you only discuss
people's vocabulary vocabulary lists in
the classroom would you have them
talking about the reading in the
classroom you know I guess it depends on
what kids will do away from the
classroom they probably won't do much
reading unless it's assigned based on
how most you know kids in school operate
I'd be interested in hearing the
experience of teachers or suggestions
from teachers we'd love to have it in
the classroom in particular now with
everybody being locked down and I think
mark indicated that where you have
classes that are locked down and we we'd
make a special deal three or whatever I
don't want to jump ahead of mark on this
but we're certainly quite happy to
support teachers and and school systems
where they're having to provide language
instruction you know somehow online and
they're struggling for the best way to
do it and we'd certainly want to help
out but by the same token we'd like to
hear from teachers on what they find
effective and dealing with we don't deal
with classes so we don't have that
experience but we'd like to learn and
see whether weakens come up with things
that can make the job of the teacher
easier using link in the classroom yeah
I mean I think we've said to anyone
who's inquired if if teachers want to
use link of for the rest of this school
year we're happy to make it available
for you with your classes just reach out
for sure next question for Steve
listening reading writing speaking which
one is most important if you want to
become fluent in English speaking I just
want to prove my abilities speaking to
me the key skill is listening
comprehension if you want to talk
to someone and you don't understand what
they're saying you can't have a
conversation so listening comprehension
implies vocabulary
first of all listening comprehension
builds up your ability to speak because
you're hearing these phrases and words
in your brains so when you go to speak
they have a chance of coming out
listening comprehension improves your
ability to read because when you're
reading in a foreign language you tend
to sub vocalize if you can hear if you
can hear how the language sounds when
you're reading you can sub vocalize
correctly so listening comprehension
helps your reading reading is a great
way to learn vocabulary we do at Linc
so to me the core skill is listening
comprehension if you if you are very
good at listening comprehension the
speaking will come the reading will come
the writing will come I mean you still
have to practice those other skills but
the fundamental skill to me is listening
comprehension um if someone is asking if
we if we would add a stone e'en as one
of the languages and and this supplies
to estonian it applies to all new
languages and we get requests to add
languages all the time we try our best
to to add languages or our conditions
for adding languages are that somebody
would need to prepare a good quality
version of the sixty mini stories and if
those are prepared then then we'll add
it no promises as to when we'll add it
it can take a bit of time to add but
well effectively if we have 60 mini
stories done we will we will looked at
it so Estonian yeah get the 60 Estonian
mini stories to us and and we will yell
at it any tips for the first-time
language learner the brain fights you so
hard it seems Steve maybe you can
comment well because it's been a long
time since I was a first-time language
learner my advice would be first of all
don't try to nail down the grammar
because until you have a lot of
experience with the language the grammar
in very complicated ways things that are
incomprehensible to you until you have
experience with the language so even a
first-time language learner the grammar
rules are thrown off as an obstacle go
to the many stories I'm more and more
commence because the many stories they
don't begin with you know key phrases
what to say at the train station at the
barber shop those things are kind of
useless basically it's just the language
with a lot of repetition and you have to
understand the brain learns the brain is
used to creating patterns to deal with
everything that comes at it in life and
if you feed it enough exposure to the
language it will learn it will learn
slowly but it will learn it'll learn
more easily that way than if you try to
either study vocabulary lists or study
grammar rules or conjugation tables
where you think you're learning
something but in fact you're not
learning so trust the idea that your
brain learns feed it lots of content and
I like the many stories because there's
so much repetition and so spend three
months with the many stories to get your
brain kind of wet in the language and
thereafter you can maybe choose a
slightly different strategy go after
things of greater interest to you you
can maybe look up some grammar rules
because you're curious about why the
language perform you know does these
certain things but begin with giving
your self lots of exposure listening and
reading and don't worry about what you
understand don't worry about what you
can say don't worry about what you
remember just expose your brain to the
language yeah I would say that's the
biggest thing that that we see is that
people have expectations that I should
learn this little part too
thoroughly before I move on and I can't
I'm having trouble learning it
thoroughly and I'm getting discouraged
and you know and that's probably part of
having of the experience they've had in
in in school where you have to learn
this dialogue and whatever like don't
worry about it you don't understand it's
fine just keep going the big
thing is is as you've just said is a lot
of exposure spend you should be
listening for an hour it's been half an
hour on the computer and if you do that
for a mod if you do that for three
months you'll improve so much so you
just can't expect results at the
beginning don't worry about it the
biggest thing I think the new language
learner lacks is that the belief that
all I have to do is just keep listening
and reading and it'll it'll happen my
brain will learn I'd learned your native
language it'll learn a new language but
you have to feed it and you and don't be
uptight don't expect to understand
I think this not being uptight is very
important like don't underestimate the
ability of the brain to resist learning
something you know when I learned
Russian of course the Cyrillic what
looks to us like a P is pronounced are
but like eight months into Russian I
would always see the P and I go P you
know in Arabic I've been at Arabic and
Persian now for well over a year and
there are letters I always get them
wrong you know the the the ands uh or
the M and the a s and I mean Chris would
not like I would get them wrong I don't
know which one it is and I've seen them
so many so many times but eventually
it'll become natural so people shouldn't
be discouraged at at what they forget
and what they continue to get wrong
that's the brain learns on its own terms
at its own speed and we can't control it
we just keep feeding it and slowly it
sorts things out someone's asking me is
there any you're going to be any further
development to the API yeah probably
right now we're quite focused on a new
version of link both web and mobile
we're working on and so there will be no
API development certainly until that's
done but if there are things that it
makes sense to expose through the API we
definitely will as time and resources
permit
any advice for those seeking to learn
small languages I've been trying to
learn Danish for years but there isn't
much material out there I mean I think
you know there's there's gotta be lots
of material in Denmark there are news
sites there's TV shows I've seen on
Netflix Danish TV shows presumably there
are videos on YouTube yeah there's not
as much but they're there you should be
able to find it but it might take a
little more work we're doing some making
some effort at link now which should
coincide with our new version where
we're gonna try to find resources in in
our languages to help people places to
import from and present them so they're
easily accessible to people I mean is it
is hard to look for resources and in in
a new language so we will be doing some
things there to help obviously at the
beginner stage I think you're looking at
many stories a lot and and whatever
other beginner content exists in all
languages and thereafter yeah I you can
make your way through authentic material
you know you kind of have to make do
with what's out there that would be my
advice
well who is speaking there well I guess
it was me I have one quick
recommendation for that it's good to get
in touch with a native speaker of that
language that you're interested in
something like I talked it would be
great for that because you can ask them
where to find the resources my Arabic
tutors from Jordan and I passed her many
times hey can you send me a radio
station or a you know a TV show that's
in Jordy and Arabic and they'll send you
that because they know where everything
is so highly recommend just trying to
get in such a people that are speaking
the language that you're looking for and
asking them for those links because
they're going
a treasure trove of knowledge for you so
I would do that can add something to
that
you're like one last thing and I'm out
as well because I have a Maya talking
teacher waiting for me for eternal
lesson so yeah hey maybe you could try
also some sunblock
I think there's in every language there
are bloggers that do write about stuff
that may interest you as well like let's
say traveling or fitness or I don't know
with relationships you know I don't know
whatever interests you you can find like
material out there there are bloggers
that do write quite like good articles
and they're quiet you know everyday
language article they're not like really
hard to read so yeah there's always you
know what serial out they're never
language probably okay wait I have done
is if I want something on take Polish
history or you know Danish whatever go
and if I'm not confident that I can
write it in the language I'm learning I
go to Google Translate I translate it
then I put it into the search field and
I can do that in YouTube I can do that
in Google so that you can then find
material YouTube is a tremendous
resource with our you know import
extension you can bring stuff in from
YouTube now assuming the Danish YouTube
video has Danish subtitles I'm not sure
that's the case but okay um here's
someone I said what do you think about
translating content of interest from
your native language into your target
language because for me it's actually
easier to find content in my own
language yeah it's easier to find
content that you're interested in in
your own language but translating it I
don't know how you're doing that
translation but that's that's gonna be
obviously way more time I think than
trying to find content in your target
language I mean I think in the end your
goal is to understand target in your
content in your target language so I
think I don't know that if that works
for you great that would not be some
that that I would do one of the things
like I've done so many different things
but sometimes if you're going after
certain kind of vocabulary and you see
it concentrated in say an English text
put it on Google Translate you've now
got a whole big text in your target
language it'll be slightly stiff
unnatural but it'll have a lot of the
vocabulary so you can then import it
into link and you can go through and
pick up that book that is one thing you
could do yeah how do you keep the
confidence to reaching fluency if it's
your first foreign language I think
we've talked about that I think you just
got to believe and keep going and and
you know after three months you'll see a
big difference after six months you'll
see an even bigger difference and every
I mean if you take it in three months
sort of segments I don't think you'll
ever find that after three months that
that you haven't made taken another
significant step in your language and
eventually you'll find that you can
function in most situations yeah how do
you deal with expectations I always tend
to want more from what I can actually
more from what I can actually do and I
get sad ideals rarely match RIA holiday
a comment on that you know a book I
refer to all the time written by manfred
spitzer on the brain and how it works
you know whenever the brain experiences
a situation where it results exceeded
expectations the brain gets a dopamine
kick the brain likes that so perhaps the
corollary there is don't put unrealistic
expectations on yourself expect that
it's going to be difficult it's gonna be
difficult to learn the language but wow
I understand something that I didn't
understand before I feel good and if you
feel good that's very motivating so it's
on its you know the these perfectionists
or people who expect to remember things
or expect that all by the end of the
week I got to be able to learn this or
that don't put those expectations on
yourself just enjoy the language be
happy with whatever you achieve and that
is actually very mode
waiting and even in terms of chemicals
in your brain apparently as Spitzer says
if you exceed your expectations if it
turns out better than what was expected
the brain gets a dopamine kick in other
words it's keen and it wants to continue
great and I think maybe we'll just
finish off with one last question here
since we're already over time someone
asset asks I'm 26 now can I reach a
native English accent I have a strong
Indian accent thank you for your advice
Wow you know my view is that it's
particularly with say Indian accents
because in India English is a big part
of their everyday life experience so
they have grown up with this accent it's
not so easy to to get away from that
it's like if you're a an Australian who
moves to Canada 50 years later you've
still got your Australian accent in most
cases whereas if you learn a completely
new language like French it may be it's
easier to develop a native like never
native I don't think you'll be mistaken
for a native but you'll get closer to it
so but if a person has an Indian accent
and they now live say in Canada or the
UK where they would rather not have such
a strong Indian accent I think what they
have to do is you know take a certain
body of content a sentence initially and
then a paragraph maybe on link listen to
it turn off the sound now read that
sentence and eventually that paragraph
read it with an emphasis on the
intonation don't worry about the
individual pronunciation of the words
try to imitate the intonation of
whatever you're listening to could be
you know British English or London or
you know whatever Australian American it
doesn't matter and try to imitate the
intonation and just do that and you
don't even have to listen to yourself
that off and like you want to listen to
what you want to imitate listen to it
imitate it get into it get into the
music of it get into the intonation of
it and and with that I think your accent
will start
move a little bit closer to the accent
that you want to be imitating but by the
same token you know Ana Marc shares this
view we have dealt with so many
non-native speakers of English who have
accents in some cases quite strong
accents we are most impressed when
people use the language well when they
use the words correctly when they have
us you know good vocabulary they speak
well they speak accurately precisely
those are the things that are most
impressive having you know a native
accent to me is a lesser lesser you know
plus but if nevertheless you know it's a
bit like vanity ok it's like you know
dyeing your hair or something if you
want to have an accent that's not cor
like a native speaker my recommendation
would be to to do a lot of working on
the intonation and I guess just in terms
of being understood it's it's rarely
actually the act the accent that
prevents understanding it's your use of
words and your use of phrases and if you
as Steve said if you have a strong
accent but you use the language well
everybody understands you perfectly
because they know what you're gonna say
they know the way the words are coming
out of your mouth they know what you're
going to say before you say it so so I
at link we always feel like you're more
you're more effective spending time
listening reading learning the language
well saving phrases in as well as word
just that just makes your language more
fluent and accent or otherwise way more
comprehensible to everybody ok great
well I think that's a good place to end
it thank you very much to our panelists
if you have had to leave at prior
commitments but thanks very much super
interesting to hear from from our
members and and feels good to know that
every that you you like good links so
much and and hopefully all our audience
participants both they here and on
YouTube have picked up some good tips
and and have employed some more
participants in the future for sure and
we'll do this again next week you can
for as long as
we'll continue to be stuck inside be
interested in participating we look
forward to it I hope hope you do as well
stay safe and be safe for sure be safe
and and I know there are some people
that also would like to be considered to
are considered as presenters so we will
we'll make that link to the register for
that available again somewhere I think
we'll put it on the forum I think it may
still be in the forum otherwise we'll
get it out there to you either in the
comments of the YouTube video or
elsewhere but to be on the lookout for
that if you're interested in presenting
otherwise yes stay safe everybody and
and we'll see you all next week
where are you okay bye bye